[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon vous voulez quoi je veux apprendre à
devenir le meilleur big bang est de
bogota est intéressant
maintenant vous travaillez pour moi avec
les règles quand vous serez sur le point
de voler un portefeuille
utilisez toujours ses deux doigts comme
une passe la foule est un terrain de jeu
idéal pour un petit bug est toujours
travail a besoin le premier titre est le
second vol et le troisième 120
cherchez-vous un troisième partenaire
moi je reste ici
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
salut il surveille ma tête tout le monde
mais moi je t'ai à l'oeil
maintenant reste là oh ouais cool les
gars qu'est ce que tu fous avec un
flingue
plus on sera de fric plomb nous enviera
et plus on risquera notre peau tu ne me
connais allez vas-y cogne je sais que tu
as une armée de demain qui pose pour toi
comme tu travailles pour moi tu n'as
qu'à mener données et aussi ils poseront
pour moi dora celui qui a tiré
qu'est ce que tu vas lui faire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que vous avez fait